the Internet is like a breeding ground
for conspiracy theories while some are
just stupid and funny others promote
ignorance and an unhealthy distrust so
we went to the courts Kazak lab and
developed a foolproof system to destroy
not all but a lot of conspiracy theories
it's really simple just ask yourself
does the theory effect really rich and
powerful people is the answer yes okay
then it's most likely not true let's
test it on three examples number one
there's an easy cure for cancer but it's
withheld because it would destroy the
profits of pharma companies hmm do
really rich people die of cancer like my
dad oh say the former CEO of Apple yes
there is no suppressed cure for cancer
number two chemtrails the theory that
airplanes spray chemicals in the air for
population control or some other crazy
reason to really powerful people breathe
air do Obama or Putin breathe air yes
chemtrails are not a thing number three
apocalyptic conspiracy theories the
world will end soon because of the
Antichrist Myers
aliens someone says so do really rich
and powerful people ignore the soon to
be upon us and very imminent apocalypse
yes the world will not end soon this
obviously doesn't work for every
conspiracy theory out there but it does
work for some of the most stupid ones so
the next time someone tries to convince
you that the Illuminati put stuff in
your water just show them this video and
maybe be a bit more selective about your
friends on Facebook
[Music]